[Applaudissements]
donc là par contre je suis bien hervé
alexandre et je vais aborder comme je le
disais un sujet dont je sais qu'il n'est
pas toujours enthousiasmant d'accord en
tout cas sans doute pas le plus
enthousiasmant de la soirée qui est la
banque
le système bancaire le secteur bancaire
j'ai l'habitude de ce manque
d'enthousiasmé et ça me rappelle une
dizaine d'années quand je me retrouvais
dans une soirée où savez ces soirées à
une coupe de champagne à la main il ya
plein de monde connaissait personne ça
peut être une conférence mais ça peut
aussi être un mariage vous connaissez
vaguement le marié ou la marie et vous
demandez comment la soirée va évoluer
vous finissez toujours pas rencontré
quelqu'un vous entamer la conversation
est la première question qu'on vous pose
c'est toujours la même c'est qu'est ce
que vous faites dans la vie on vous
demande pas qu'est ce que vous aimez on
vous demande qu'est ce que vous faites
dans la vie
à l'époque je répondais universitaires
comme je répondrais aujourd'hui ça se
passait plutôt pas mal parce que
universitaire est un métier plutôt
plutôt respectée par contre là où ça se
corse elle où ça devient très difficile
c'est à la question suivante le relais
mais sur quel thème vous travaillez je
vais pas mentir je t'ai vu obligé de
répondre la banque
et là d'un seul coup je voyais que je
perdais 80% du capital sympathique jeu
venait d'acquérir en disant que j'étais
universitaire j'ai des dizaines de fois
j'ai rêvé de pouvoir dire je suis
chercheur en littérature médiévale jeu
sûr j'aurais eu beaucoup plus de succès
c'est comme ça je vais vous êtes rejet
de vous parler de la banque
alors là la banque est un sujet
extrêmement intéressant elle souffre
effectivement d'un désamour profond
depuis un certain nombre de temps
d'accord et pour être plus précis depuis
2007 2007 va être une année alors dans
ma présentation extrêmement importante
qui reviendra régulièrement d'ailleurs
mais pour la banque et la finance est
aussi une période extrêmement importante
en pourquoi 2007
pas parce que 2007 c'est la crise
financière est sans doute la crise
financière la plus importante de
l'histoire contemporaine largement aussi
important que la fameuse crise de 29
d'accord il se passe quoi dans cette
crise financière en 2007 bien certains
banquiers américains certaines banques
américaines vont créer et utiliser des
produits extrêmement rentable mais d'une
dangerosité qu'ils n'auront jamais
mesuré et un moment tout éclate parce
qu'en finances quand on fait n'importe
quoi
d'accord à un moment ça ça se retrouve
ça se rattrape et ça éclate
est ce qu'il va se passer c'est qui va
sauver les banques et ont commis ces
erreurs en 2007
d'accord ça va être les états les
déposants les contribuables d'accord et
sobre il a tellement ça laisse des
traces
donc depuis la crise financière les
banques ont du mal à essayer de
rattraper leur image même s'ils n'ont
pas toutes participé d'accord à cette
erreur alors d'habitude quand il ya
d'autres crises financières ce qui a
quand même des crises financières assez
régulièrement il faut bien l'avouer
d'accord au bout de deux trois ans le
régulateur intervient et et on oublie un
peu ce qui s'est passé alors pourquoi on
n'oublie pas parce qu'en fait on se rend
compte que si on veut acheter une maison
à un appartement une voiture bien on va
bien trop obligé d'aller d'aller dans sa
banque
donc la banque va être incontournable
une entreprise c'est le pour investir et
donc créer des emplois elle va également
d'accord devoir aller rendre rendez-vous
à sa banque
donc ça rend la la banque d'accord comme
quelque chose d'incontournable et en
fait on finit toujours par pardonner aux
erreurs des banquiers est pourtant là là
ça marche pas on est en 2010 neuf ça
fait 12 ans et on voit bien que les
banques ne redémarre pas comme elle
aurait pu le faire il ya trente ans il
ya 40 ans d'accord suite à une autre
crise alors il ya plusieurs arguments
qui sont avancés on parle de problèmes
macroéconomiques on peut parler de
problèmes politiques on veut parler de
l'ensemble pas même moi je vais en
retenir un qui est très particulier
d'accord qui a comme premier point
commun d'avoir émergé en 2000 c'est donc
on retrouve cette cette fameuse année
2007 alors ce dont j'ai envie de vous
parler maintenant c'est l'iphone alors
vous noterez que ça c'est l'iphone de
d'accord il est plus petit il un peu
plus plus trapu on va dire d'accord mais
en même temps il ressemble quand même
encore à ce que vous avez pour la
plupart d'enfants dans vos poches ce que
dira qu' à l'époque en 2007 c'est le
vita révolution on a quelque chose alors
qui sert à téléphoner mais globalement
pas tellement et moins en moins mais qui
va servir à gérer son calendrier à
prendre des photos envoyer des photos
d'accord à retrouver son chemin à
connaître la météo si on a envie de
connaître la météo et le l'utilisation
de l'iphone va se développer va exploser
avec dans les mêmes années facebook
c'est 2007 aussi d'accord à peu près
arrivé en france
d'accord avec l'arrivée dès réseaux
sociaux
les réseaux sociaux sur le téléphone sur
l'iphone ou sur les téléphones des
concurrents d'accord va générer une
utilisation extrêmement intensive
d'accord de ses téléphones portables
je suis sûr je vous vois pas ce que
l'âge et la lumière dans les yeux près
toutes les fenêtres
même si l'éclairagiste est très bon
c'est quand même un petit peu de lumière
dans le jeu donc je vois pas mais je
suis prêt à parier que 20% d'entre vous
à peu près vous avez votre téléphone
posé sur la table
vous pourriez avoir dans votre poche
dans votre sac d'accord mais vous l'avez
sur la table est sur la table parce que
parce que vous guetter une notification
parce que vous avez l'habitude d'accord
d'avoir toujours votre téléphone avec
nous alors je vous critiquent parce que
moi même je les ai dans ma poche je
rêverais sans doute de l'utiliser mais
là pour le coup ça se verrait et je vais
quand même pas me permettre
d'accord de faire ça devant vous de
sortir mon téléphone
même si depuis des années je rêve de mon
quart d'heure steve jobs vous pourrez
marcher sur une scène une scène comme ça
avec un iphone dans la main ils vont
s'assurer je ne suis pas studio
malheureusement donc comme l'iphone va
s'avérer quelque chose ou le smartphone
va serrer choses extrêmement important
utilisé en permanence au bout d'un temps
les banques vont s'inviter dans le
téléphone
et elles vont donc créer des
applications qui vont faire que
progressivement on va pouvoir faire de
la banque avec son téléphone donc dans
une salle dans le train dans le métro
n'importe où on va pouvoir tirer de
l'argent vérifier son compte bancaire
effectué des opérations basiques mais
des opérations ses nombreuses de ben
voyons ça se sont créé également
d'autres d'autres entreprises qu'on
appelle des fines t comme cela vous a
été dit précédemment d'accord est encore
plus près nous que vous intéresser des
nues aux banques alors une et aux
banques c'est quoi pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas une aux banques
c'est une banque qui n'a pas d'agent ce
sédiment qui n'a pas d'existence
physique qui n'a généralement même pas
de site web
on sait une banque ou par laquelle on
peut ouvrir un compte uniquement avec
son téléphone ça prend 10 minutes c'est
extrêmement simple extrêmement pratique
extrêmement rapide on n'est pas obligé
d'attendre que le banquier et petit
déjeuner et fasse le chemin jusqu'à la
banque pouvoir le contacter on peut
contacter sa banque à n'importe quel
moment effectuer d'opérations qu'on veut
à n'importe quel moment également est
donc en train de prendre le chemin d'une
banque digital et cette banque digital
ben elle arrive progressivement à se
priver d'êtres humains il n'y a pas
besoin d'humains ou très très peu
anne chabot un programme bien écrit donc
il faut un informaticien effectivement
un peu de mathématiciens et une fois que
la banque ait lancé la place de l'humain
est réduite au minimum
donc la question cela question que je
vous pose est ce que je voulais essayer
de répondre en tout cas d'apporter une
réponse partielle ce soir est ce qu'il
ya de la place pour l'être humain
d'accord dans la dans la banque de
demain je vais essayer d'apporter
quelques réponses alors vous permettrait
de partir sur des chemins qui sont pas
des chemins bancaire parce que si on
restait sur la banque on aurait une
approche trop technique et je dois
essayer voir vous convaincre vous
expliquer de ce phénomène vous parler de
ce phénomène sans rester dans la bande
donc on va commencer par un ouvrage d'un
auteur que j'adore que j'aime beaucoup
que ça fait deux matchs ou crawford
alors matthew crawford a à peine à
réaliser une telle une thèse de
philosophie aux états unis au début des
années 2000 il a été embauché dans un
think tank pour lequel il a il a rédigé
des rapports assez nombreux assez variés
puis très rapidement il s'est rendu
compte qu'ils s'ennuyaient alors ils
s'ennuient et pourquoi parce qu'en fait
il voyait pas trop à quoi servait son
boulot il savait pas ce que ce que
devenait lé rapport qu'il avait rédigé
puis finalement ça l'intéressait pas
donc il s'est installé comme réparateurs
de motos de collection moto d'occasion
parce que c'est sa passion et qu'il aura
envie de faire des choses qui le
passionnait
il a écrit son premier ouvrage parce
qu'il a quand même une thèse de
philosophie donc il a quand même eu une
envie d'écrire
il s'appelle éloge du carburateur alors
pourquoi l'âge du carburateur parce
qu'ils s'intéressent ils s'interrogent
sur le travail dans ce premier livre il
se dit finalement ce qui est extrêmement
intéressant je répare une moto c'est
d'abord le contact physique
le contact réagir le retour d'accord à
la réalité et c'est également le fait il
un chapitre faut être fort pour un
chapitre sur la réparation d'un
carburateur d'une moto d'occasion y
arrivent très bien il explique qu'en
tirer par le carburateur d'une vieille
moto qui n'est plus produit depuis les
années 50
la seule manière de savoir comment je
dois réinstaller carburateur qu'elle est
longue je dois m eh bien ça il le sait
n'ont pas des livres
il ne s'est pas de la tuerie le sais
parce que c'est la 5ème 6ème moto qui
leur est pas et qu'il s'est rendu compte
par apprentissage par connaissance de
son métier que s'il décalé légèrement
carburateur il met au point une moto qui
marchait mieux ça c'est son premier mais
comme je suis vraiment un gros fan de
matthew crawford j'ai rapidement acheter
son deuxième livre qui s'appelle contact
aurait aussi une moto parce qu'il est
passionné de moto est dans ce livre dans
ce livre et là ça nous rapproche
peut-être un peu plus de notre sujet
initial il constate que l'ensemble de
nos activités ou en tout cas une part de
plus importante de plus en plus
importante de nos activités subi
l'interface d'un écran ou d'un
algorithme quoi qu'on fasse aujourd'hui
on le fait aider d'un algorithme aidé
d'un ordinateur ou d'un téléphone
alors il prend l'exemple de la moto et
de l'automobile et lit par exemple
aujourd'hui pas une auto sans même
parler des voitures autonomes mais une
auto une auto vont va vous aider à des
algorithmes vont vous aider à bien
démarrer à ne pas accélérer trop vite à
ne pas être trop proche de la personne
avant si vous arrivez trop vite dans un
virage il ya tout un ensemble
d'algorithmes qui vont ralentir la
voiture que pour que vous preniez le
virage dans des conditions de sécurité
optimales
donc ça c'est extrêmement confortable
c'est extrêmement positif
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait se
plaindre que quelqu'un pense à fabriquer
des voitures d'accord qui sont plus
sécure et plus confortable que les
voitures 10 à 30 ans personnes par
contre ils s'interrogent est dû au bout
d'un temps si la voiture corrige les
défauts de l'être humain
quand est ce que l'être humain va
apprendre à conduire en fait
et dans le cas d'une moto quand est ce
qu'un être humain va apprendre à piloter
alors on va dire passe on s'en fiche
puisque on va bientôt à une voiture
autonome et finalement d'accord
apprendre à conduire n'aura bientôt
qu'un intérêt lebresne section fait ça
ont réduit progressivement nos espaces
cognitif on va apprendre de moins en
moins de choses parce qu'en fait tu aura
de moins en moins de choses à apprendre
à quelques programmateur qui écriront
des programmes d'accord très intéressant
et les utilisateurs vont désapprendre
les choses qui étaient pourtant
relativement basique jusqu alors donc ça
c'est plutôt c'est plutôt une inquiétude
c'est plutôt un point négatif à cette
digitalisation dont je suis très fan par
ailleurs voyez pas en moi d'accord
quelqu'un qui vit dans une grotte et qui
critiquent décrit un écran un téléphone
je suis plutôt très fan mais je vois
également par l'utilisation que j'en
fais quotidienne d'accord les limites et
les dangers
alors avant de revenir à la banque
puisque c'est également mon sujet
initial vers faire un détour où je vais
m'éloigner encore un peu plus d'accord
j'espère surprenait pas trop avec un
film alors il a une particularité ce
film c'est que déjà il est sorti en 2007
toujours cette fameuse année 2007
ensuite film s'appelle wali c'est un
film qui a été produit par pixar wall-e
c'est quoi au lycée le petit robot voyez
ici au milieu de l'écran d'accord alors
sans vous résumer le film ce sera un peu
trop long d'accord wallis un robot qui a
laissé sur terre pour trier classer et
ranger les déchets les êtres humains ont
tellement pollué la terre elle n'est
plus habitable
ils sont partis vivre sur un vaisseau
assez loin dans l'espace un vaisseau
gigantesque d'accord ils ont laissé
quelques robots nettoyer en espérant
qu'un jour peut-être ils pourront
revenir habiter sur terre ce petit robot
tombe amoureuse amoureux puisque c'est
un nouveau masque d'un autre euro d'un
état ou d'une autre robot il le hasard
fait qu'il se retrouve dans ce vaisseau
d'accord où vivent les humains et on
voit j'ai choisi cette photo il se prête
on voit de quoi
eh bien on voit que les humains d'accord
il ne marche plus ils ne conduisent plus
d'accord il ya plus d'automobiles tout
et faire passer là il marche même plus
ils ont des sièges qui sont extrêmement
confortables d'accord est qui et qui
bouge à leur convenance ya plus à faire
l'effort de marché il ya même plus à
faire l'effort d'acheter des chaussures
d'ailleurs puisque l'on ne s'en sert
plus puisqu'on ne marche plus encore un
peu plus graves
d'accord on voit ici que les deux les
deux personnages sont en train de parler
un écran ce qui peut déjà être un peu un
peu inquiétant est plus inquiétant c'est
qu'en fait ils sont en train de se
parler l'un à l'autre mais ils ont perdu
l'habitude de le faire juste en se
regardant juste en tournant un peu le
visage en sortant de cet environnement
digital et algorithmique pour juste
regarder l'autre être humain est élu par
les simplement d'accord donc c'est en
train de se parler par et quand leur vie
se résume à l'écran et à ces chaises qui
bouge tout seul pourquoi je vous ai
parlé tout ça alors que le sujet
d'origine c'était la banque la banque
digital pas parce que ça ça reprend ça
illustre d'accord des progrès de la
banque digital et ça en illustre
également des dangers alors des progrès
badé progressé qu'à l'évidence la bande
de malfrats digital est à l'évidence
elle sera dans nos téléphones
elle y est déjà c'est extrêmement
pratique j'ai pour essayer ouvert des
comptes dans différentes ni aux banques
c'est extrêmement simple utilisation est
limpide et pratique
donc je pense que la question de la
banque digital ne se pose quasiment pas
en tout cas pas en ces termes là par
contre on peut également parler d'une
banque digital qui a été créée par
carrefour il ya quelques quelques années
cette banque s'appelle sésame
carrefour a créé une haie au boss qui
étaient très intelligents à l'époque
d'accord c'est relativement simple fait
qu'un fonds vient d'annoncer récemment
qu'ils allaient arrêter cette néo banque
sésame d'accord et pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils vont l'arrêter
pas parce qu'elle est mauvaise
financièrement pas parce que les
coûteuses pas parce qu'elle n'est pas
efficace
ils vont à fermer parce que les clients
ne viennent pas et les clients ne
viennent pas dans cette banque
parce qu'ils lui reprochent de ne pas
être assez humaine donc l'année aux
banques sésame de carrefour va fermer
parce qu'il n'y a pas eu assé d'humains
et en fait l'idée de cette banque du
futur qui serait digital
elle sera digital c'est une évidence
mais elle devra aussi être foncièrement
humaine parce qu'un humain quand il a
besoin d'un service de renseignement
financier est bien quelque part il va
finir par supporter les hésitations les
erreurs du bon qu humain qu'il aura en
face de lui alors ça va agacer on sortir
andorre la suisse est elle toujours pas
compris ce que je voulais mais en même
temps on sera content d'avoir pu
s'adresser à quelqu'un qui peut partager
nos inquiétudes et nous et citations
donc je voulais vous dire ce soir c'est
qu'à l'évidence la banque de demain sera
digital et je trouve ce ce domaine
extrêmement passionnant mais il faudra
surtout pas comme d'autres secteurs
d'ailleurs de l'activité économique qui
nous entoure il faudra surtout pas que
les acteurs de la vie économique
oubli l'humanité dans la création de
leur entreprise dans la re création de
valeur avec leurs clients je remercie
beaucoup de votre attention
[Applaudissements]